qué cree usted y Cuál es la importancia
de este globo en la diplomacia
y creo que las tensiones han ido
incrementándose entre Washington y
Beijing fundamentalmente luego de la
visita Nancy pelosi entonces me parece
que en este tercer mandato de del
presidente chino hay una Clara tendencia
a incrementar la confrontación con
Estados Unidos a nivel global esto se
produce paralelamente al acuerdo entre
filipinas y los Estados Unidos de un
aumento de las bases militares entonces
creo que estamos frente a una situación
que se puede se puede ir puede ir
aumentando en la escalada de digamos de
este tipo de situaciones bueno Y como
ustedes bien lo mencionó hubo un nuevo
pacto entre Estados Unidos y filipinas
que se firmó el 2 de febrero un pacto
con el que Estados Unidos amplía su
presencia militar en el país asiático
accediendo a cuatro bases militares
filipinas esto china lo ve como una
amenaza porque filipinas es el país él
tiene su territorio más cerca de Taiwán
en caso tal de que haya una guerra Allí
se está preparando Estados Unidos para
una eventual conflicto en la isla
bueno
el objetivo fundamental geopolítico en
El Siglo 21 Estados Unidos y China
apuntan básicamente al despliegue
militar en esa región sumar a filipinas
sería tener el primer cordón de Islas
para contener a China ahí también
jugaría un rol muy importante en Japón
también es una forma de contener a China
sobre Taiwán y lógicamente tendríamos a
Corea es muy cercanamente teniendo un
rol muy estratégico pero sí estamos
frente a una situación de complejidad
fundamentalmente en el mar del sur de
China y esta situación de complejidad
como usted La Llama a esto se adiciona a
otro episodio que ha hecho distanciar a
China y Estados Unidos esta misma semana
Washington bloqueó las exportaciones de
cualquier producto a la compañía china
Huawei cuál cree usted que son las
consecuencias de esto en la relación
entre los dos estados
bueno incrementa la atención entre ambos
estados se sabe perfectamente que es una
es todo lo que es la tecnología de
telecomunicaciones muy sensibles tanto
para los Estados Unidos como para china
hay una una escalada de una competencia
internacional se sabe que la ruta de
seda china sobre diferentes regiones
también en América Latina que está
llegando apunta a tener un espacio en
este Nicho y bueno eso es un área
accesible porque se trata de el control
y el monitoreo de las comunicaciones y
lo que también se sumaría a la diploma
Sí el manejo de la vidaca entonces me
parece que es una atención muy grande
entre ambos países y que va a continuar
en esa mesa de negociación